our foreign adversaries and now more
than ever
from our domestic ones this job's
important
we've seen this deport this department
turmoil over the last four years with
six different secretaries
ali mayorkas will can bring the kind of
steady hand that this department needs
i'm going to tell you when ali asked me
to introduce him i thought to myself
words can't do this man justice
this is somebody that was made for
public service
he spent most of his career in the
department of homeland security
he understands the challenges he
understands it's going to take a lot of
work
he understands we're going to have to
bring people together
and he understands that this is a 24
7 job i would hope that this committee
would kick out alami orcas pass him out
better term pass him out and get him to
the senate floor so we can get confirmed
because honestly after the events
on january 6 we have no time to waste
thank you for your time
thank you senator tester our witness
this morning is alejandro
mayorkas president-elect biden plans to
nominate mr mjorkus to be secretary of
the department of homeland security mr
merrick has previously served as the
deputy secretary
of the department of homeland security
as well as the director of the u.s
citizenship
and immigration services it's a custom
of this committee miss miraculous who
swearing all the witnesses so at this
time
i'd ask you to please stand and raise
your right hand
do you swear the testimony you'll give
before this committee will be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth so help you guide
i do
noting that the witness is answered in
the affirmative
your written testimony mr muricus will
be printed in the record in its entirety
and we will now ask you to try to limit
your oral
testimony to five minutes please begin
when you're ready
thank you mr chairman mr ranking member
members of the homeland security and
governmental affairs committee
i am honored to appear before you as the
nominee to be the next secretary of the
united states department
of homeland security it would be the
greatest privilege of my life
to return to the department and lead the
nearly 240
000 men and women who dedicate their
talent and energy
to the safety and security of our nation
i appear before you not alone but with
and because of my family my wife tanya
and our beautiful daughters gisele and
mimi enable and inspire
me to serve they understand
that my heart is in government service
they
are the heart of my heart and i say to
them
i love you
the principles of homeland and security
have been tremendously important
in shaping my life my father and mother
brought me to this country to escape
communism and to provide me with the
security
opportunity and pride that american
citizenship brings to each of us
i was raised to appreciate each day what
this country has meant for our family
and the blessing it is to know what is
our homeland
the love for this country that i learned
from my parents
only made the january 6 attack on our
capital
all the more horrifying if
i should have the honor of being
confirmed i will do everything i can
to ensure that the tragic loss of life
the assault on law enforcement the
desecration of the building that stands
as one of the three pillars of our
democracy
the terror that you felt your colleagues
staff and everyone present will not
happen
again the department of homeland
security bears an extraordinary weight
on behalf of the american people
the weight of grave challenges seen and
unseen
cyber attacks that undermine our
security and the integrity
of our information systems the threat of
both foreign
and domestic terrorism pandemics
like the one that we are living through
now that throw every part of american
life off of its axis
and extreme weather events that threaten
lives
and livelihoods this is to say nothing
of maintaining border security providing
humanitarian relief
protecting our critical infrastructure
or the many other responsibilities
that the department fulfills each and
every day
if i have the privilege of serving as
secretary i will work day and night to
support the department's great workforce
and ensure that it is able to execute
its responsibilities
successfully with honor and dignity
i will dedicate myself to equipping the
department's men and women
with the tools and resources they need
and providing them with the
opportunities they deserve
i will do so in partnership with you and
with the other members of congress
and with the department's many other
critical partners throughout our country
the department of homeland security is
fundamentally
a department of partnerships to combat
the threat of terrorism
the department must work with our
international partners
other federal agencies state local
tribal and territorial governments
and our nation's noble first responders
to enhance our cyber security the
department depends upon
and must strengthen its cooperation with
the private sector
to be prepared for and resilient to
natural disasters the department must
work with state
local tribal and territorial governments
and our brave
local fire and emergency personnel
to facilitate and enhance our travel and
trade
it must innovate and align its research
and development
with the efforts of private industry and
academic institutions
to meet the challenges and the
opportunities of migration
it needs to collaborate with other
nations international organizations
and non-profit service providers to
succeed the department must work
with the many communities it serves
this committee and your colleagues in
the senate in the house of
representatives
are at the forefront of the department's
partners
we must work closely with you as you
help determine the funding
upon which the department relies
promulgate the laws that it is charged
to enforce
and provide the oversight that ensures
its accountability
to the american people as your partner
the department must be collaborative
open and transparent and at all times
forthright with you
even in times of disagreement if i am
confirmed as the next secretary
the department will meet its
responsibilities to you
i began in government service as a
federal prosecutor
after more than eight years trying cases
before juries
i served for three years as the senate
confirmed united
states attorney as a prosecutor
the law and the facts of a case were my
foundation
and my guide and they have remained my
north star
ever since have worked in support of
federal agents and officers
local law enforcement firefighters and
emergency medical technicians
i have worked in support of all the men
and women throughout the department
of homeland security and in public
service who work in
and even rush into harm's way to protect
us all
i have not for a single moment lost
sight of what a privilege
and honor it is to do so nor of the
obligations it carries
on our nation's behalf i look forward to
continuing
that service thank you
thank you mr marcus uh we will now have
seven minute rounds and
you know my pattern is normally to as a
chair
to go straight to others because we have
a a good
mix of republicans and democrats who are
lined up to speak but there are some
things that i think are important
to address so i'm going to take some
time here at the beginning as well
before we get started there are three
questions the committee asked of every
nominee and for the record let me just
ask you to respond to each one quickly
first
is there anything you are aware of in
your background that might present a
concept of interest
with the duties of the office to which
you've been nominated no
second you know anything personal or
otherwise that would in any way prevent
you from fully and honorably discharging
the responsibilities
of the office to which you have been
nominated no
and finally do you agree without
reservation to comply with any request
or summons to appear and testify before
any duly constituted committee of
congress
if you are confirmed yes
thank you for those answers uh
again there's lots to discuss today and
i look forward to a dialogue on some of
the homeland security challenges we
face and and and your uh proposals to
deal with those
but let's go straight to the issues
raised by this dhs inspector general's
report
on decisions you made during the time
you were
director of the u.s citizenship and
immigration services
the report documented how you intervened
in these three cases related to the eb-5
investor visa program this is where
people are
given a visa with the understanding that
they'll come and invest in the united
states and create jobs
a few specific questions uh the
inspector general
in the case of la films regional center
involving ed rendell
stated that you and i quote created a
deference review board staffed with
individuals
you handpicked to review a separate
series of time warner movie projects
this board did not previously exist and
was never used again
after it voted to reverse the
adjudicator's proposed denials
remarkably there's no record of the
proceedings of this board
that's from the ige report first
is that accurate and second how do you
explain that there was no record of the
proceedings
of the board mr chairman thank you for
the opportunity to
answer your question and address that
aspect of the
inspector general's report and i should
say at the outset
mr chairman that i have tremendous
respect for the
system of inspectors general uh they
provide tremendous value uh to the
agencies and departments throughout the
federal government
and the opportunity for leaders to
improve the organizations
uh that they oversee and i have always
cooperated with the inspector general's
report including
uh this uh inspector general of the
department of homeland security
senator there's an underlying principle
to your question which i will articulate
and then answer your questions
specifically and that is that when
a leader enters federal service
with the authority to fix problems
that leader has the responsibility to
fix
problems and that is what i did
and the eb-5 investor visa program that
uscis
u.s citizenship and immigration services
administered
was plagued by problems and i heard
about those problems
almost every single day that i served as
the director
and i heard about them from both sides
of the aisle
in every corner of the business
community that the agencies served
and one of those problems was a very
significant one
which was when the agency made a
decision
in an eb5 investor visa case and
millions and millions of dollars of
investor capital and the creation of
jobs for u.s workers was dependent upon
that decision
was it fair for the agency to later in
the
adjudicative process change its mind
and kill the business development that
was designed to infuse capital
into economically disadvantaged areas
and create jobs
for americans and so i created
the deference review board as but one
fix to the many problems that we
encountered in that agency
and that fix was an institutional reform
that was supposed to endure
throughout the life of the eb5 program
office that i created and when i read
the inspector general's report
that was the first time that i learned
that the deference review board had not
been gathered together
uh after the case that you mentioned and
the fact that
during the case that you mentioned a
record had not been kept
and if i had remained the director of
u.s citizenship and immigration services
rather than having assumed the
responsibilities of becoming the deputy
the
deputy secretary of homeland security i
would have ensured
that the deference review board
continued and its proper record-keeping
practices
were adhered to
okay uh as deputy secretary
didn't you have the opportunity uh to do
exactly that to be able to
ensure that in a management role as
deputy secretary that the
uh the visa program was working at the
deference review board was properly
functioning
mr chairman when i became the deputy
secretary of homeland security
we instituted reforms in response to the
inspector general's report
uh to ensure that the integrity and the
ethics
of our leaders were well understood by
the workforce
and the public that we serve i delegated
responsibility
to the management of the eb-5 program to
the new director
of u.s citizenship and immigration
services that led it
the dhs ig report also explains how you
intervened in a denial related to gulf
coast regional center where terry
mcauliffe
was chairman of the board and anthony
rodham former secretary of state hillary
clinton's brother
was the ceo the report documents how
both men
contacted you about the denial the
report states that you personally
reviewed the denial decision before it
was issued
disagreed with its finding and indicated
you would rewrite the decision yourself
witnesses testified all these actions
were outside the normal judiciary
process
one is this accurate and two if so
why did you go outside the normal course
uh
senator let me let me share if i may
something with you about the ev5
investor
visa program and the agency
of u.s citizenship and immigration
services
uscis that is as it is commonly known
is an agency that adjudicates cases
that's what it does
it um it addresses the
applications for immigration benefits
that millions and millions of people
submit to it
each and every day and so when i
uh had the authority and therefore the
responsibility to fix
problems i fixed problems through the
cases that the agency handled
the case that you mentioned in three
cases that are cited
in the inspector general's report are
three
of hundreds and hundreds of cases
that i became involved in at the request
of senators and members of the house of
representatives
on both sides of the aisle and
i do i must say senator take issue
with the use of the term intervene it is
my
job to become involved to learn the
problems that an agency confronts
to become involved in those problems and
to fix them
and that's what i did in this case and
the many cases that came before me
that were presented to me on both sides
of the aisle and
i find it my responsibility uh to be
responsive
uh to members of congress on a
bipartisan basis and i commit to you
that i will honor that obligation should
i be confirmed
as the next secretary of the department
of homeland security
final question uh what did you learn
these were politically connected
individuals where you were in direct
contact with them going around the
typical adjudicatory process
did you have concerns that your actions
might be viewed as favoritism and
special access
and what did you learn that helped you
as a deputy secretary and would help you
should you be confirmed
as secretary senator
i learned something very important from
this report and it is for that reason
that i am
grateful for it and i should say that as
an individual both in my personal life
and my professional life i learn
and i learn each and every day to be
better tomorrow
than i am today and that is a commitment
that i carry forward throughout my life
i learned that individuals in the eb-5
investor visa program and therefore
in the agency may not have full
visibility
of all that i am involved in and all of
which i do
as a leader and therefore they may take
a slice of my action
and gather misperceptions of
what fuels me as a leader and what
drives me
as a government servant because if i may
senator
these weren't the only three cases i was
involved in
were dozens and dozens whether they
involved the rich
or the poor the enfranchised or the
disenfranchised
i became involved to ensure that our
agency
improved each day that i learned of the
problems that we were confronted with
and then i did everything to fix them i
don't take these jobs
senator i don't drive to be a government
servant
and serve the american public to cut
ribbons
around the country and have fun i work
really hard and i have worked really
really hard throughout my nearly 20
years
of government service to bring honor to
the office that i have been privileged
to occupy
thank you senator peters
thank you mr chairman mr mayorkas thank
you again
for your answers to those questions uh
mr mayorgravers the kova 19 pandemic is
without question the the crisis of our
time and uh
we must uh dedicate every effort to
overcoming it
dhs has played an integral role in covet
19 response
thus far with fema staff managing the
logistics and the medical supply
acquisition
and distribution cbp officers have been
identifying counterfeit medical products
and cisa is safeguarding coved 19
vaccines from
both physical and cyber attacks however
as you're well aware
there's still much more work to be done
so my question to you sir is if
confirmed what would be your priorities
to ensure the expansive resources of the
department
can further advance our nation's
response
to covet 19 crisis ranking member peters
the
covet 19 uh pandemic is one of the
greatest challenges that we in the
department of homeland security
and across the federal government and
quite frankly as we all know too well
throughout
uh our entire nation uh must confront
and the department of homeland security
has significant capabilities to bring to
bear
in that fight in execution
of the president-elect's ambitious and
visionary vision
for putting this pandemic once and for
all behind us the federal emergency
management administration
fema as it is commonly called has
tremendous reach
through its 10 regional offices
throughout the country
in ensuring uh that the supply chain is
effectively executed
to bring the needed relief the needed
equipment in the needed vaccines
to the american public the cybersecurity
and infrastructure security agency or
cisa
as as it is commonly known has the
awesome
responsibility of protecting that supply
chain
from cyber attacks and ensuring that the
work of the other
offices and agencies in the department
of homeland security
are executed without threat from either
foreign or domestic
actors the reach of the department is
significant
and i hope i have the privilege of
leading the department
to bring this covet 19 challenge uh to
rest
put it behind us and let us prosper in
the days ahead
orcas uh uh this uh committee uh in the
the day
in the days weeks and months ahead we'll
take a uh
a look at how we responded to this
crisis uh to see what worked and uh what
uh
did not work and then make sure that we
are better prepared for
a future crisis my question to you
generally now is in your opinion and
seeing how the department uh has
responded to this crisis
what do you think are some of the
biggest lessons that were learned
from the pandemic response
senator let me say that i i look
forward to studying the performance of
the department of homeland security and
the execution of its responsibilities
to tackle the covet 19 pandemic and i
look forward to doing so
uh working closely with you with this
committee
on a bipartisan basis i look forward to
understanding
whether the mandate to the department of
homeland security
remain consistent clear and well-defined
uh throughout the many months that we
have been battling
covet 19 to make sure that the
department's resources
have been exploited to the fullest
extent possible in the best meaning
of that term and that in fact its
responsibilities were executed
uh efficiently and effectively i look
forward to working with this committee
to study how the department performed
and what more it can do in battling
uh the pandemic well i'm happy to hear
that because there's no question
that the oversight of the government's
response to covet crisis is going to be
a top priority of this
committee going forward and
my question to you is if confirmed will
you commit to providing this committee
with all the documents information and
access to individuals with knowledge
as we conduct this critical oversight
i do uh
mr mayorkas i have uh too far too often
met with resistance in my attempt to
conduct an
investigation into the threats of white
supremacy
and domestic terrorists in our
communities the trump administration
did not do an adequate job in addressing
this very real threat
and our threat that we saw played out
in black churches mosque and synagogues
over the last few years i can tell you
that african-american
arab american and jewish families in
michigan as well as all across the
country
are relying on this new administration
to keep them
safe where they live work and they pray
if confirmed what steps will you take to
tackle this persistent
and growing threat to our nation
senator peters ranking member peters
uh two very important points one
i commit to you that if i am confirmed
as the next secretary of homeland
security the department
will be open transparent and responsive
to this committee
on a bipartisan basis number one number
two
the threat of domestic extremism is one
of the greatest challenges that the
department of homeland security
confronts
and it has unique capabilities in uh
confronting that challenge its office of
intelligence and analysis
is a critical uh partner with state
and local tribal and territorial
governments
in gathering information and
intelligence about the threat that we
face here at home
and disseminating that information so
that our brave and noble first
responders are best equipped to tackle
it
i look forward uh to playing a critical
role
in empowering the office of intelligence
and analysis
in an apolitical non-partisan way to do
its important job
and tackle the the threat that domestic
extreme extremism
uh is today mr mayor is the the events
of january 6 have
renewed calls for increased
prosecutorial and investigative powers
to respond
to domestic terrorism additional powers
uh
could be duplicative and harmful to the
very communities
that we seek to protect including nearly
300 000 arab americans in my state that
have been
targets of hate crimes and
discriminatory counterterrorism
policies the federal government already
has authorities to
effectively investigate and prosecute
domestic terrorism but unfortunately it
has failed to
prioritize those existing resources to
counter the obvious
the open and growing threat from
anti-government white supremacy
conspiracy oriented and other violent
extremist groups my question to you is
will you commit today
to prioritizing existing statutes and
resources to combat
white supremacist violence and undertake
the extensive consultation
[Music]
with me and leaders of the arab american
and other minority communities before
pursuing new domestic terrorism
authorities
to prevent future attacks uh if
confirmed
yes ranking member peters i will thank
you i should say if i may
uh sir that um uh when i was the united
states attorney for the central district
of california
uh i created uh for the first time in
the office's history
a civil rights section uh to focus on
the prosecution of hate crimes which was
a growing
problem back in the late 90s
thank you mr chairman mr mayorka so
welcome back
in the six years under my chairmanship
this committee held
dozens i think well well over three
dozen hearings on
the problems of the border and that was
really sparked by what happened in
2014 when president obama declared
humanitarian crisis
when we had the surge of unaccompanied
children as well as family units
come across the border illegally one of
the things
i certainly did i didn't have time to
blow these things up but
i started developing charts to kind of
lay out the problem
what i'd like to do is quick go through
a little bit
get some quick responses from you in
terms of the history of this i know
senator feinstein credited you with the
daca program
i've been arguing i think accurately the
daca program
as beneficial it is for people and
addresses a particular problem
also he was used as a catalyst by
coyotes
and created the surge that produced that
2014
humanitarian crisis where 137 000 people
in total
you uncover children and family units
across this border illegally
and we had to deal with that and the
obama administration recognized that and
your
deputy secretary at that point in time
uh just quick answer these questions
in reaction to that it is true that the
obama administration built the facility
in mcallen texas correct
yes sir and that's the same facility
that has the
chain-link fences that people on the
other side of the aisle have
referred to as putting children in cages
correct yes sir
um you you started that detention
process because you recognize this is a
problem so you started detaining those
families and those uncomfy children
correct
um senator um the detention
establishment in immigration and customs
enforcement
existed long before so you so you could
but you continued you detained
individuals correct
correct we we detained uh individuals
as part of the immigration and customs
enforcement
operations precisely you also separated
children from their
the adults that they arrived here
correct
there were there were children separated
from parents back in 2014 correct
yes or no senator johnson uh when i was
the deputy secretary of homeland
security
i explicitly rejected uh the
um proposal to separate families but it
occurred correct
senator i can't uh so okay dad
regardless the enforcement actions the
obama administration took
actually had an impact we went from 137
000 down to 80 000
in 2015 but then a court reinterpreted
the flores decision and included
accompanying children for those same
protections
and you can take a look at the result it
took a little while for people to
realize how they could exploit that
problem
to the point in 2019 we had 608
000 people arriving and coming this
country illegally
basically apprehended and then released
and dispersed through this country that
was a real problem
and this administration addressed it
with the mpp program
uh different agreements with
central america and we dramatically saw
a decrease
in the amount of people coming in here
risking their lives in a very dangerous
journey we saw a dramatic decrease well
before covid
another chart we have is is daily
average daily entries illegal entries
per month you can see we hit a high a
peak
in may of 2019. again this is when the
administration
this current administration started
implementing
solutions to the problem and by and
large
we dramatically decreased that what's
been happening over the last few months
is we've had a dramatic increase now in
terms of
single adults coming here and we see a 9
000 person
caravan coming from honduras and they're
they're very open in terms of why
they're doing it because president-elect
biden has
sta stated in the debates that we're not
going to deport anybody in the first
hundred days so they're going to take
advantage of that opportunity
so i guess my questions for you is
secretary johnson who you served under
said that 1 000 people per day was a bad
day
we have been consistently over 2 000
today
for the last number of years over 4 000
day in march 2019 right now we're back
over 2000 per day
do you consider that a problem what what
is going to be a bad day
if your secretary department homeland
security of illegal entry
senator johnson um i've had the
privilege of
addressing this uh these issues with you
before
uh when i was served as the deputy
secretary of homeland security and
and candidly of course several weeks ago
when i became the nominee
to be the next secretary of homeland
security i look forward to studying the
data
with you and actually being open and
transparent with you okay but
again what what will a thousand a day be
a bad day or is
two thousand acceptable is three
thousand acceptable what's going to be a
bad day
on your watch let's just just give pick
a number senator
uh i i look forward to okay i don't have
time for
okay so next question do you believe
economic
coming into this country illegally for
economic improvement is that a valid
asylum claim
senator the the asylum laws are well
established
and they provide that an individual
who's fleeing persecution
by reason of his or her member in a
particular social group
uh is deserving of protection okay but
but coming here for economic gain is not
a valid asylum claim is that
would you agree with that i believe i
articulated
the legal theory and it and okay
um will you commit to provide
this senator this committee the type of
data at least the data we got so i can
continue to
monitor what's happening at the border
so i have full information so we can
really see what's happening based on
whatever policies you
implement yes i committed to you uh that
i would do so
when we last spoke and i commit to you
now do you also commit to enforcing
our current immigration laws fully
enforcing them
okay just real quick i know senator
portman did a pretty good job of talking
about the eb-5
and the office inspector general report
i would ask this committee
i received a letter from senator
grassley with about 138 pages of
documentation i'd ask that that be
entered into the record i'd also ask
that the
i'd also ask the report by the office
inspector general to be entered in the
record
i just have a couple quick questions
the the main problem i i'm assuming you
got that letter from senator grassley
dated january 15 2021.
yes senator have you responded to that i
i'm about to senator
i think again there's a lot of detail in
here a lot of your
testimony was contradicted by what
you've done
you said you're supportive transparent
in being forthright this committee
senator grassley in a letter is one of
the attachments august 23 2013
his main issue in writing this letter to
you is you have not been forthright you
have not answered questions dating back
to his oversight letters 2013
but one of the points he makes in this
august 23 2013 letter is
the questions for the record response is
in direct contradiction
of your hearing testimony goes on to say
this contradicted what you had
previously told my staff which was you
were never
involved in individual cases so again i
would just ask
the members of this committee in
evaluating this nomination to seriously
take a look at this
uh letter from senator grassley with his
exhibits that he's that i've now entered
into the record
there are some pretty troubling uh
issues raised by senator grassley i
don't know you want to quickly respond
to that i'm out of time
um i would very much like to um if i may
senator and mr chairman may i respond to
that
i became involved in a lot of cases
because as i said the work of u.s
citizenship and immigration services
is case work and i did my job
and i learned of problems and i fixed
them as a matter of fact
one of the areas in which i became very
involved
is in the area of international
adoptions
and i learned of that area and i learned
of the problems that afflicted it
because senator grassley brought a case
to my attention
involving an international adoption that
had become
stuck in a bureaucratic nightmare
and i jumped in and i learned about what
was going on in our international
adoption system
at the request of senator grassley and i
learned a lot
from becoming involved in that case and
then senator grassley's concerns
were echoed by senator landrieu who
called me one day
and said that we are stuck in moving
orphan children in guatemala to
their welcoming homes and families in
the united states
and i created a task force to look into
that
and to tackle it and i traveled to
guatemala three times
uh to see what i could do with
government leaders in that country
to work through the bureaucratic
nightmare
that was causing tremendous suffering on
the behalf of
children who were looking for homes and
a humble
faithful american families that had
opened their homes and their families to
those children
that didn't have anything and i became
involved in those cases
and i fixed that problem and the
international adoptions from guatemala
began to move
and i brought justice to the case that
senator grassley
presented to me and i did so based on
the facts and the law
and nothing more and i keep to this day
i keep to this day the letter of thanks
from senator grassley for my involvement
in that case
i remember with great pride
attendance at an affair with senator
grassley and senator landrieu to
celebrate
the humble and faithful american
families that opened their homes
to children in need and i have to this
day
a photograph of an orphan child
running through an airport with a big
smile on his face
because he's about to be embraced by his
american family that has opened their
home to him
and that is not the case of the rich and
the powerful
that is the case of the poor and the
disenfranchised
i got involved in a lot of cases
and i did right by the cases i got
involved in
and the inspector general did not take
issue with the disposition of the cases
in which i became involved
because i studied the law and i followed
the facts
and that is my north star and it always
has been
and any suggestion to the contrary is
incorrect
senator carper thanks mr chairman uh ali
uh welcome uh welcome back to uh hearing
appearing for our committee i want to
thank tonya your wife i want to thank
your daughters
uh giselle and mimi for their
willingness to share you
with the american people and all these
roles that you've been
privileged to to play ali mayorkins is
an american success story
sled cuba at a young age with his family
left everything came here for the hope
of
living a better life and has done
remarkable things he's
one of those people who feel that given
the gifts that he's gotten from
being becoming a citizen of this country
he has an obligation to give back and he
has given back
again and again and again
we've seen this movie before this eb5
movie we've seen
before we saw it seven years ago
it was fully discussed and fully
litigated
let me just say every one of us as a
united states senator
can think of a time probably many times
when folks that we represent they could
be business people
they could have been folks of non-profit
organizat
in a bureaucratic tangle this is a big
government we have
and it's easy to get things messed up
and sometimes that happens we're
expected
is the representatives from our states
to stand up for people and try to
straighten things out as much as
anything that's what
ali's been accused of all those years
ago
and i uh i i just want to say this
most most of uh the folks that are on
our committee today
we're not in uh in the senate in 2013 i
don't think and uh
i was chairman of this committee i was
chairman of this committee
and i remember very well the effort to
smear this man's character
based on a 2013 inspector general
investigation which was
leaked to the press a day before his
confirmation hearing
a day before his confirmation here in
serious violation
of ig protocol following that the
claims were made were fully investigated
by a subsequent
inspector general and mr mayorkas was uh
found to be guilty of one thing and
that's creating an appearance
of favoritism if we were to be honest
with one another
every single member of this committee
and in the senate could be accused of
the same thing at one time or another
for trying to do really
the right thing and what's more the iit
who initiated this investigation who was
responsible
for the original leaks in 2013 resigned
later that year
resigned in under allegations of
misconduct
he was charged last year with fraud
if anyone still has any doubts there
they should read the final ig report
including mr marioka's 32 page response
for themselves
to allow these unfunded allegations to
cloud ollie majors's unblemished career
and
public service at a time when this
department so critically needs
principal leadership capable leadership
i think it's irresponsible at best and
dangerous at worst it's marcus
everything i do i know i can do better
i'm going to just ask you to
talk to us about what you did to improve
the morale of the workforce that
the department of homeland security and
especially at uscis
what did you do and prove it and did it
ever improve under your leadership
senator carper thank you very much i um
i was very proud of the fact that the
employee morale at u.s citizenship and
immigration services improved under my
leadership
and that the morale of the men and women
of the department of homeland security
improved during my tenure as a deputy
secretary and under
secretary johnson's leadership um
i i prioritized the morale
of the men and women of the department
of homeland security and the agency that
i led
in the first term of the prior
administration
we uh focused on equipping
the workforce with the tools they needed
to perform their jobs availably
and in a manner which they could be
proud of we created
opportunities for them to advance in
their careers
and fulfill their highest ambitions i
can
be granular in some of the
recommendations and some of the fixes
that we implemented
but let me just speak to the fact that
if indeed i have the privilege
of serving as a secretary of homeland
security
i will make the well-being and morale
of the brave and noble men and women of
the department
my highest priority let me uh
thank you let me just say of colleagues
when ale malayakis and jay johnson were
confirmed to lead
the department of homeland security for
the last four years of the obama
administration
what they found at the department of
homeland security as some of you recall
was
i call it uh leadership
by swiss cheese we had so many uh people
in acting positions positions that were
unfilled in leadership
and tom colbert and i worked together
with a lot of our colleagues at the time
to make sure that they we fill those
positions at hearings
voted confirm people and then uh
conducted the
the oversight that we're expected to to
conduct
my colleagues will recall about every
year there is a
really a survey that's done of major
departments within the federal
government
with respect to morale year after year
after year the department of homeland
security
uh was dead last dad laughs the last
year that uh ali mariokas and jay
johnson led this department
my recollection is it was the department
that had the best improvement
in their final year of their leadership
i'd ask us to keep that
that in mind i uh
ali one of our colleagues has raised the
issue of uh
illegal immigration people coming across
our border you and i have been down to
uh central america we've been down in
honduras guatemala and salvador
we found over the years there's three
reasons why people come
out of those countries to get to our
country and one is we make their lives
miserable
our addiction to drugs illegal drugs and
the traffic of those drugs through those
countries
just creates a power and money for
criminal units and what we have done
is basically after putting these people
in those countries in
a terrible situation basically we build
a wall to keep them out
when they're trying to get here there's
something called the alliance for
prosperity which creates
three buckets for us to put money into
the federal government
other countries foundations nonprofits
in order to go after crime and
corruption
to try to make sure that there's
economic opportunity for people
and the the that's what we've done
through the alliance for prosperity
you know what it works because we go
after root causes would you comment on
this please
going forward senator carper uh
president-elect uh
biden and vice president-elect harris
have put forth a
bold vision for addressing the root
causes
of irregular migration from the northern
triangle countries
one cannot overstate the push factor why
individuals seek to leave their country
of origin their homes because of
extraordinary
violence because of corruption
because of extreme poverty because of
persecution we must address
the root causes to
to solve the problem in the western
hemisphere
in our region specifically that is what
president-elect biden's vision does and
i hope i have the privilege to execute
it as a secretary
mr chairman if i could just in closing
if any of us
lived in those three countries and had
to put up with a crime and corruption
a lack of economic opportunity we try to
get out of there
as well and we would come to the kind of
a wonderful country that ali mayorkas
and his family came to all those years
ago
they want to stay in their countries we
have an opportunity in this new
administration to make sure they have
something worth standing for
thank you very much thank you mr
lankford
i think i'm sure i'm going to take out
my mask since i let me be within 15 feet
of me at this point so
mayor thank you again uh for stepping up
in your service uh again
in this process let me run through just
some very quick questions for you i've
got quite a few to be able to run
through but
a lot of these are just getting things
out of the way will you protect the
rights of whistleblowers
access to the inspector general in
cooperation with this committee if
you're the
secretary of homeland security yes i
always have and we'll continue to do so
thank you do you see your role and this
is a prospective issue do you see your
role as the leader of dhs
as the leader of a law enforcement
agency or a law interpretation or
reinterpretation agency
the department of homeland security is
charged with enforcing the laws
that congress passes thank you if
there's someone in the administration
that pushes you encourages you uh
to um not enforce the law or to ignore
the law as the secretary of homeland
security what would be your response to
them
i am an officer of the court i always
have been
you um you've heard the statement before
and you and i have talked about it
before
would you recommend that ice be defunded
no does ice need actually additional
support
uh senator there i will have to study uh
the condition of immigration and customs
enforcement
how efficiently and effectively it is
using its resources
and how it is best serving the american
public
and that requires my study we'll look
forward to getting a chance to get a
follow-up on that study
uh would you recommend any of the
physical barriers along our southern
border be dismantled or removed
senator i i haven't looked at that
specific question i will share with you
the fact that i agree with the approach
that
then senator mccain an american hero
in my family and in this country that
senator mccain
took to the border which is it's not a
monolithic
challenge of the border uh the border
is varied um depending on the geography
depending on the specific venue and to
spending
depending on the conduct of individuals
around it and we don't need uh nor
should we have
a monolithic answer to that varied and
diverse challenge
right i would assume that it's 2000 mile
long border uh we've got many areas that
are mountainous open desert areas
that i would fully agree don't don't
need a physical barrier
uh we have lots of uh site lines there
we can do it with other technology other
enforcement means on that
is there any area of the border that you
would see now
that still needs additional repair for
physical barriers
additional increase in technology or
would need an expansion of physical
barriers
senator i um i look forward to studying
that because i am well aware
of the challenges that the border
presents um i am
very well aware of the fact as senator
johnson
alluded to that traffickers are seeking
to exploit the border
and not only to move people across it uh
illegally
uh but to move contraband to move
fentanyl uh the narco
traffickers have sought to exploit the
current uh
challenge of the covet 19 pandemic and i
look forward to studying the border to
make sure that those challenges are
repelled
the border agents that i've spoken to
there along the border tell me of two
things on physical barriers one is it
slows people down so they're able to
interdict
as they're trying to climb the wall get
around the wall get under the wall we're
able to get access to
those individuals and be able to
interdict faster in that sense so it
becomes a deterrent
it also pushes people towards the point
of entry where they can manage those
families and individuals a lot easier in
that
sense in a more reasonable environment
rather than being in a very remote area
so i look forward to that ongoing
conversation you and senator johnson had
to interchange back and forth on this
very straightforward question
is economic opportunity a valid reason
for asylum
you quoted the asylum statute on that
but i guess the the yes or no question
on that is
economic opportunity doesn't seem to be
in the statute as a valid reason for
asylum so i guess
the the question i have for you still is
is economic opportunity a reason that
should be added to it
it's not there do you believe it's there
senator i i um
i'm a lawyer by profession so i take a
look at the laws
and i enforce them as both a lawyer
and as a law enforcement officer for
nearly
20 years of my my career
when one speaks of economic opportunity
what does
one mean just generally an opportunity
to make a better living
if that is uh what you are referring to
that
my understanding is that that does not a
legitimate
asylum claim make and that's our
understanding of the law as well and it
seems a pretty plain reading of it that
if someone is coming to increase their
economic opportunity
obviously almost any country in the
world any city you live in in the world
there's improved opportunities in the
united states and we're grateful for
that in the united states
but just saying hey you don't have a lot
of economic opportunities where you live
doesn't mean you open up our borders
for asylum claims or to say we're going
to somehow
release you into the united states and
debate it there's been an ongoing
conversation about how to be able to
manage that how to be able to do it
let me ask you a difficult question this
can be hard to be able to interpret at
this point because you haven't faced it
yet but pretty likely will
in the days ahead as the leader of dhs
it's pretty likely
you're going to have thousands of people
coming across the border in a migrant
caravan from honduras
pretty rapidly what message would you
want to give to those folks right now
that are traveling north
in that migrant caravan to be able to
send a message to them that if you're
confirmed as the secretary of homeland
security
this is the message they need to hear
about when they arrive the united states
um uh senator um uh let me say at the
outset that this is not the
first caravan uh that has uh uh
apparently approached the border over
the last four years or
it's not over the last 12 years um the
the phenomenon of
of a caravan is something that we have
confronted in the department of homeland
security
uh for many years i think uh
president-elect uh biden
uh and uh people who will be joining his
incoming administration
have spoken about the fact that um uh
there is a commitment uh to follow our
asylum laws to enforce our
asylum laws and that means to provide
humanitarian relief for those
individuals
who qualify for it under the law
that cannot be accomplished with just
the flick of a switch
and turned on in day one that it will
take time
to build the infrastructure and capacity
so that we can enforce our laws
as congress intended and that would be
the message i would send
so let me ask this the title 42
authorities being currently used at our
southern border right now because of the
covid
risk we have 21 of our officers and
agents
that have died because of covet
trying to be able to interdict
individuals that they then acquired
covid
and have died in the line of duty it's
been incredibly difficult
on the entire department on that to be
able to watch that
as you go through the memorial to agents
listing that's out there for dhs
you see 2020 is a year where we just
have all of those agents listed out
there and you realize the pain of what's
really occurred in this time period
do you anticipate changing the title 42
authorities
that currently exist to be able to
protect our agents and individuals in
the united states
from individuals traveling from very
high profile covet areas
do you anticipate changing that senator
i appreciate the question very much and
i'm very well aware
of the loss of life of our brave
uh front line personnel i have met
with the border patrol council that
represents the border patrol agents
i have met with the nteu
the the organization that represents
customs and border protections office
personnel
i am very proud of the fact that both
organizations have supported my
nomination
and i look forward to studying title 42
authorities
what they provide and i can say this
unequivocally
uh that our highest priority is to
protect the health and well-being of the
american public
i would i would hope that we wouldn't
have different rules for people flying
in from honduras
than we have illegally traveling from
honduras because right now we have
pretty strict travel restrictions coming
in
if you're flying in legally and if
somehow we have a different set of rules
it's
lacks if you're traveling here illegally
that would be quite a quandary for us to
be able to explain to everyone how the
rule of law prevails
so thank you for stepping up there is a
lot to be able to do and i look forward
to ongoing conversation thank you
senator
senator hassan
uh mr chair i was going to uh switch
places with senator
cinema who has a scheduling issue if
that's all right with you
that's that's uh understandable and
senator syndrome are you with us
i am uh thank you so much mr chairman
and i want to thank senator hassan for
her kindness i appreciate it
so uh thank you so much mr chairman for
holding this hearing today
and i appreciate that mr mayorkas is
joining us today
it's critical that the department of
homeland security
has a senate confirmed leadership as
quickly as possible
so my questions today will focus on
several topics related to border
security and immigration
which are key issues in my state of
arizona and i also hope to discuss a
cyber security issue
i remain committed to finding bipartisan
and common sense solutions
to secure arizona's border and protect
the public health and safety
while also treating migrants fairly and
humanely
so mr mayorka is my first question for
you dhs
faces a critical challenge at the border
with the new administration considering
changes that would allow more asylum
seekers to enter our country
in the midst of a pandemic this will
especially be a challenge for arizona
the wall street journal recently
highlighted that our
state is the nation's covic 19 hot spot
we have the highest
infection rate per capita and our
hospitals are all
at or near capacity so what steps do you
plan to take if confirmed to ensure that
dhs
develops a covid19 testing strategy that
protects our communities while ensuring
asylum seekers are treated fairly
senator thank you very much for your
question
uh president-elect biden and his
incoming team
have spoken very powerfully about both
aspects of the question that you pose
number one uh that the health and
well-being
of the american public is the highest
priority
and the president-elect has laid out an
ambitious
uh vision for tackling the covet 19
pandemic that has caused our nation
so much pain um and i look forward to
the opportunity should i be confirmed
to be the next secretary uh to be a part
of that
vision uh and that plan um
the president-elect uh and his incoming
team have also spoken of the commitment
uh to enforce our asylum laws
so that we provide humanitarian relief
to those who
qualify under them in the proudest
traditions of our country
that will take time and i hope i have
the privilege
of being a part of that effort as well
thank you most federal workers are
slated to get vaccinated through county
allocations
but counties along our southern border
in arizona are struggling with a
disproportionately
large percentage of phase one b
essential workers that includes our port
officers and our border patrol agents
they work so hard to protect our borders
and ensure the flow of trade
the recent news that dhs employees can
access vaccines from va medical centers
is promising
but border communities like yuma and
douglas are more than two hours by car
from the nearest viewing medical centers
in tucson and phoenix
in order for all dhs employees to be
assured fair and equitable access to a
coronavirus vaccine
options should be available at
community-based outpatient clinics
when confirmed can you improve vaccine
distribution and access for our dhs
workforce
senator one of my highest priorities as
i have had the um
a privilege of articulating earlier in
this hearing
is the well-being of our men and women
throughout the department of homeland
security
and i am well aware of the challenges
that our frontline personnel
confront especially because they often
are confronting congregant settings that
only increase the risk
of the spread of covet 19. i look
forward to studying
the issue should i be confirmed of
working in an all of government effort
to protect the government workforce
across the federal architecture
especially of course in my priority area
of the department of homeland security
and of course of the american
public writ large
thank you during the 2019 surge of
asylum seekers at the border
the efforts of arizona non-governmental
organizations
and our local governments to aid
migrants who've been released by customs
and border protection was absolutely
critical
your prepared remarks describe the
department of homeland security
as a department of partnerships i agree
and i believe that partnering with local
governments and organizations
especially in border communities is
critical if you're confirmed will you
and arizona dhs leaders work with me our
ngos and liberal governments to improve
communication and cooperation regarding
border security
asylum seekers and immigration and the
flow of trade across the border
i would be honored to do so senator
thank you
last congress i was proud to work with
senator cornyn to pass my southwest
border security technology improvement
act
this critical law will make sure that
dhs properly analyzes technology gaps
along the border and develops smart
solutions to fill them
i hope you work with me in my office as
you develop the analysis required by
our law to ensure our nation tackles
border security in effective and
efficient ways
what are some of the initial border
technology challenges you want to
examine once confirmed
senator i i would be honored to work
with you to ensure
that we are harnessing uh the best
innovation uh the best advances in
technology to ensure
border security and not only border
security in terms
of tackling the challenges that we have
been speaking about
in this hearing uh but also in
facilitating and promoting
lawful trade and travel uh to really
modernize
our ports of entry uh and to facilitate
the lawful flow of cargo and people uh
that add to the prosperity of our
economy
i think the challenges are considerable
considerable uh as are the opportunities
i look forward to working with the
office of science and technology in the
department of homeland security
to ensure that it is adequately
resourced and partnering
with the other parts of the department
the other parts of the federal
government
and harnessing the capabilities and
opportunities in the private sector and
academic institutions
to make sure that we're bringing an all
of government and all of society
approach
to meeting the challenges and
opportunities of the border
i appreciate that my time is rapidly um
closing down so i'll quickly ask my last
question about cyber security
it's a critical issue in arizona we've
had ransomware attacks
on arizona medical education and
governmental organizations
and the threats are growing so we want
to emphasize education about cyber
hygiene early and often to
get ahead of these threats so we work
with my office
and me to explore opportunities to
enhance cyber education programs
in arizona and nationally i will senator
thank you mr chairman i yield um well
i'm over my time
thank you for your intelligence and mr
chairman and again thanks to senator
hassan for allowing me to
to speak ahead of her i appreciate it
very much thank you senator cinema
senator romney
thank you mr chairman mr mjorka nice to
see you
uh appreciate your wife being here and
your daughters
i'm sure your daughters are enjoying
seeing you on the hot seat i'm sure
they've had that experience themselves
with you uh a couple of things i want to
follow up on something senator lankford
opened which is apparently a caravan
moving in our direction
what is your intention with regards to
that caravan
uh that is coming to our our border is
your intention to allow them to come
into the country will they be stopped
what what's the what's the plan
senator um uh
we are a nation of immigrants and we are
also
a nation of laws and i intend to apply
the law in the execution of my
responsibilities as the secretary of
homeland security
should i have that privilege i
understand that and and what does that
mean
in this in this regard does that mean
that they will be interdicted and
and rejected from coming to the country
evaluated one by one what's the uh
what's the plan
senator uh when people present
themselves at our border we apply
the laws of our nation to determine
whether they qualify for relief
under our humanitarian laws or whether
they don't
kind of uncertain there but i presume
that means that they will not be allowed
just to
come into the country that these people
will be stopped at the border and
processed one by one is that correct
senator i apologize if i was uncertain
if people qualify
under the law uh to remain in the united
states
then we will apply the law accordingly
if they do not qualify to remain in the
united states then they won't
thank you um the chairman senator
chairman
portman raised a number of issues with
regards to the eb-5 uh program and
and your involvement in what appeared to
be political favoritism
uh and he asked you what lessons you've
learned from that
i had the experience of serving as a
governor and and now as a senator in
each case i've had a chief of staff
who have acquainted me with anything
that might provide the appearance of
favoritism
or conflict of interest of some kind
political or economic
sometimes i don't notice those things
and they bring them to my attention you
should not involve yourself
in this decision because it may be seen
as being inappropriate and as a result
you might lose the confidence of
american people who entrust you
to carry out your responsibilities
without favoritism
i would have anticipated that when
senator portman asked you what have you
learned from this process that you might
say
i have learned from the process that
when something appears to be political i
should recuse myself
is that not a lesson you learned with
regards to this looking back on these
circumstances
should you have not said because i have
been called by
a leading democrat whether governor
rendell or
or others of that nature that in a
circumstance like this because of my
political connection
i should recuse myself and let
others take that responsibility is that
is that not
the appropriate action to take when
something has the very distinct
appearance
of political favoritism
uh several parts because
um uh the eb-5 investor visa program
is a program that involves
very very significant complex business
developments
uh that involve hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars and it was broken
and so to for me to recuse myself from
the program in its entirety would have
been for me to abdicate my
responsibility oh of course
no i'm only suggesting with regards to
when an individual who
happens to be a leading democrat would
call you that that meant holy cow i got
to step back
well senator on the one hand i was
very responsive to members of the united
states senate in the house of
representatives on both sides of the
aisle
and i prided myself on my responsiveness
and i commit
to continue in that responsiveness we
did
we did establish guard rails to better
protect
against the appearance or the perception
of favoritism as a result of the
inspector general's findings and i would
adhere
to those guard rails and findings
accordingly i did in fact learn
senator had to how to better guard
against the perception
and i agree with you 100 percent that it
is our
obligation to guard against that
perception
so that there is trust and confidence in
the decision-making of government
leaders
thank you um some
time ago i toured the border
with our nation in mexico uh in san
diego
and uh and met with the head of the uh
the union
responsible for keeping our our border
safe and he said look the
the wall is helpful but it's not gonna
stop uh
people coming across the border as long
as we have such a big magnet
and i said what do you mean a big magnet
he said well if people are able to get
paid ten dollars an hour from working on
our side and only one dollar an hour
from working on the other side
they're gonna find a way in uh and uh
and from that i recognize the importance
of the e-verify program
uh basically as something to punish
american employers that hire people who
come here illegally
um do you support the e-verify program
is it an
important tool should it be mandatory
should it be permanent is this
an essential element of protecting our
nation
and the uh the opportunities of of
employment
uh for so many of our people today
who've been put out of work because of
the covid crisis senator
when i was the director of u.s
citizenship and immigration services
under my leadership we made tremendous
improvements
to the e-verify program and under my
leadership
enrollment voluntary enrollment in the
e-verify
uh program increased dramatically
i would look forward to studying uh the
utilization now
of the eb-5 program its effectiveness in
the business
community its effectiveness in achieving
its intended purposes
and i would look forward to working with
you as i study the effectiveness of that
program
i i assure you that i will be happy to
work with you to see if we can't get e
verify as a more effective
a tool for policing employers who hire
folks that have come here
illegally i'll leave one
question without much opportunity for
you to respond to given my time
but uh but i've had the occasion of
working someplace and wondering
how i would do things differently than
my boss
you've worked uh as the number two at
the department of homeland security you
probably looked at what your boss did he
was a great leader
but you probably got some ideas yourself
as to the things you would like to do
differently
one that certainly has come to your mind
is with regards to our cyber security
uh we are woefully uh unprepared
from a cyber security standpoint uh in
this nation and in our government
and and hope that as you you look at
this agency and your new
responsibilities
assuming you are confirmed that you will
focus on uh on bringing
a whole different level of expertise
both
in defensive actions with regards to
cyber security and offensive actions
uh and uh and protect our our government
uh and our
economy uh from those who would uh who
would attack us
in this new uh most powerful way
uh senator if i if i may respond um uh
uh briefly
i was incredibly proud to be the deputy
to secretary
johnson secretary johnson prioritized
a very evolving cybersecurity threat and
we made tremendous advances in the
department
under his ultimate leadership
the threat has only evolved and only
grown since there
and i can since then and i can assure
you that the cyber security
of our nation will be one of my highest
priorities because i concur with you
that the threat is real and the threat
is every day
and we have to do a much better job than
we are doing now
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
romney senator hassan
well thank you mr chairman and ranking
member uh for having this hearing
i want to thank senators feinstein and
tester for introducing our nominee today
and i want to thank you
mr mayorkus for your service and for
your continued willingness to serve
and i want to thank your family too
because nobody does this by themselves
and it's a huge family commitment
so uh please everyone know how
appreciative we are
i want to start with a question about
domestic terrorism we have seen a
disturbing and alarming rise in domestic
terrorism throughout the country
culminating of course in the violent
attack on the united states capital 13
days ago
the department of homeland security was
created after 9 11
largely to address the lack of adequate
information sharing
about terrorism-related threats despite
the fact that the threat of terrorism
has
evolved and changed in the nearly 20
years since the 9 11 attacks
no comprehensive federal review of
terrorism information sharing
has occurred to keep pace with the
evolution of these threats
to address this senator johnson and i
introduced last congress
a bill to establish a federal
inter-agency commission
to re review both domestic and
international terrorism information
sharing
and what you have seen in the prep in
the preparation for your confirmation
and comparing it with your time as
deputy secretary
do you feel information sharing on
domestic and international terrorism
is adequate uh senator uh
thank you very much for your question uh
the department of homeland security
plays a leadership role um in the
collection
of information with respect to the
domestic and foreign terrorist threat
and the dissemination of that
information of the office of
intelligence and analysis
is particularly on point and i think
that we can do
a lot better in the distribution
of that information to our brave first
responders
in local communities throughout our
country and i would look
forward to working with you in this
committee to make sure that that
interagency task force of which you
speak
is built uh and is its responsibilities
are executed
most effectively well thank you for that
one of the things that
uh i learned over time as governor is
that it is one thing to talk about
information sharing and
and coordination it's another thing to
actually invest in it and make sure that
it happens and clearly we need to do a
better job at
it in this in this area then i want to
ask you a couple of questions to follow
up on what senator romney started to
talk about on cyber security
the solar wind cyber attack revealed
vulnerabilities
across the government in the system
designed to prevent such a far-reaching
attack
as secretary you will be charged with
immediately reviewing the adequacy
of two department of homeland security
programs the einstein program
and the continuing diagnostics and
mitigation or
cdm program in order to understand why
they did not detect
or prevent these intrusions do you have
any initial
thoughts on the performance of these
programs and whether any fundamental
changes will be required to either
senator i look forward to um
to studying the solar winds attack of
course i've been
studying it uh intensely as a private
citizen
should i have the privilege of serving
as the secretary i will avail myself
of the best and latest intelligence that
the united states has
with respect to this attack and
conducting a thorough review
of einstein and continuing doc
continuous diagnostics and
mitigation to understand whether
einstein and cdm
as as it is commonly referred to are
appropriately designed and appropriately
and effectively
executed to stop a threat such as solar
winds and if not
what other defenses need we develop
in the federal government to best
protect
our very valuable equities and resources
thank you i look forward to working with
you on that as well
um let's turn to state and local cyber
security for a minute
in december senator paul and i held a
hearing to examine the impact of the
coven 19 pandemic on state and local
entities
as they work to defend against cyber
threats
one of the witnesses was dennis goulet
the president of the national
association of state chief
information officers and also the
commissioner of new hampshire's
department of information technology
in his testimony commissioner goulet
implored congress to authorize
a stand-alone federal cybersecurity
grant program
that would help state and local entities
afford to take the steps that they need
to strengthen their information
technology systems
the national governors association and
several other entities have echoed this
call
mr mayakis when you consider the current
state of federal support to state and
local governments
would you support a standalone grant
program
moreover what elements of a grant
program would need to be included in
order to make an effort like this
sustainable senator you you raise a very
very important point because in
in the cyber security world we often say
that we are
only as strong as our weakest link and
we have to recognize
that there are local communities that
don't have the financial or other
wherewithal
to really safeguard uh their cyber
assets and best protect
against the threats that they confront
and there are a number of different
solutions
that we need to consider whether it is
improving our information sharing
so that the best practices of one
geography are shared with other
geographies and we raise
the bar across the board and also to
your very valid
uh point senator whether we should
institute
a federal grant program uh to provide
assets
uh to those communities uh that don't
adequately that don't have them
adequately
to deal with a very sophisticated uh
threat
i look forward to considering a grant
proposal and working with you
in that regard thank you i think there
are other grant programs that we do out
of dhs
or doj that really um on our physical
defenses
uh try to play this role and i think
it's time for us to catch up to that
kind of
grant program in the cyberspace so i
look forward to to working on it with
you
um why don't i yield back the rest of my
time if
if there is a second round mr chair i i
have a couple of more questions but
thank you very much
great thank you senator hassan senator
scott
senator scott your audio is not coming
through can you
maybe go up dude
let's try it again
yeah we did it can you hear me now
that sounds better oh okay
okay thank you for the opportunity
senator scott we're still not able to
hear you um maybe
there's a way to turn up your microphone
or come closer to the computer
all right i'll just get closer to the
computer how's this is this better
that's much better okay how's that
and i think your your belief was that um
that there were other things to do
besides having a um
the border wall uh to uh to provide
security when you look at them
when you look at the caravan and then
you look at the video today of
that caravan walking and you're really
just pushing through the watermelon
butterball and police force how would
you
how would you handle something like that
on the border if we
didn't have a border wall
i i think um uh uh senator scott and mr
chairman i think i
captured uh uh senator scott's um
question uh when i served as the deputy
secretary
and um i met with uh the border patrol
uh both at headquarters and in the field
uh along the southern border uh
what i heard uh from the border patrol
was
uh that we need a diverse approach
to border security that in some
instances a physical barrier would be
effective
but that in other instances
more boots on the ground would assist
and yet
in other circumstances uh the use of
technology the use of
uh aaron marine uh assets uh would be
most effective and i look forward to
studying
uh the challenges at the border and
developing a
sophisticated uh approach to meet those
challenges to sure that
to be sure that we're harnessing uh
innovation and technology
um to the best of our
so yeah with regard
would you call would you
construction that's going on how the
existing plans
uh senator scott president-elect biden
uh has committed um uh to stop
construction
of the border wall it would be my
responsibility
uh to execute that on that
and i have not uh looked at the question
of what we do with respect to the wall
that already has been built and i look
forward to
studying that question understanding the
costs and benefits
of doing so uh being open and
transparent with you and with
all members of this committee uh sharing
my thoughts and considerations
and working cooperatively with you
towards the solution
thank you mr president we talked about
this the other day could you
could you repeat your position with
regard to uh funding
uh border patrol to meet those
challenges to sure that
to be sure that we're harnessing uh
innovation and technology
um to the best of our
so with regard
would you call would you construction
that's going on
the existing plans
uh senator scott uh president-elect
biden
uh has committed um uh to stop
construction
of the border wall it would be my
responsibility
uh to execu that uh on that
and i have not uh looked at the question
of what we do with respect to the wall
that already has been built and i look
forward to
studying that question understanding the
costs and benefits
of doing so being open and transparent
with you
and with all members of this committee
uh sharing my thoughts and
considerations
and working cooperatively with you
towards the solution
thank you we talked about this the other
day could you
could you repeat your position with
regard to uh funding
uh border patrol and ice and and whether
you think we should continue
uh to fund them or we should abolish
them uh
the senator uh
[Music]
you know we have and the
federal funds have been the biden
administration is thinking about
billion dollars out
threats and look forward to doing so
this committee thank you
thank you mr chairman senator
cheating last
appreciating last uh forward to hearing
more
about your plans this year our homeland
treating immigrant communities
with treating immigrant
communities with and respect admits the
global present threat of cyber attacks
domestic serious committee to facilitate
facilitate a swift confirmation for our
country
asked the first question about
protecting doc
asked the first question about
protecting daca and tps
programs well they provided critical
pensions to an estimated thirteen
thousand and thirteen thousand daca
recipients and more than four
thousand tp's nevada from college
students
small business owners and medical
professionals and members
optionals and members of our armed
forces
however the trump administration
relentlessly targeted these programs
causing
significant dress and uncertainty and
uncertainty within our communities
this is all the more troubling is
thousands of daca and tps our frontline
administration must train in these
programs to protect dreamers
and programs
to protect dreamers
and tps holders
so how do you plan
senator uh thank you
uh the presiding congress
on day one uh
with a permanent
solution in passing
um legislation
uh to fix our much uh
also has committed to
reinstituting the daca
program that i was mission services
and president-elect biden
also has committed to
following commonly known
um to populations
who qualify for
i look forward uh
to executing uh
the president's commitment
and one final point on this
we do have a lot of tps recipients
process to provide more certainty
some of these recipients who've
been here for decades
uh congress in finding a permanent
solution
to immigration reform and the needs of
individuals
uh who have been resident uh in this
country for many many years and have
contributed uh to its uh well-being
a temporary protected status uh has
statutory
uh requirements uh that uh we
in the obama biden administration were
very proud uh to apply
in adherence to the law uh and in the
service of the equitable and
humanitarian considerations
that the law contemplated i look forward
to doing so
in close partnership with you in this
committee
thank you um you know in the past few
years we have uh seen an alarming
increase in domestic anti-semitism
and white supremacism supremacist
extremism
from neo-nazis chanting jews will not
replace us in charlottesville
to the deadliest attack against the
jewish community in modern american
history at the tree of life synagogue in
pittsburgh
just this month we saw you american
citizens lay siege to the u.s
capitol waving confederate flags hanging
a noose on the west front lawn
and wearing camp auschwitz t-shirts
despite the fact that dhs concluded last
year that racially and ethnically
motivated
violent extremists specifically white
supremacist extremists
will remain the most persistent and
lethal threat in the homeland
the department has not adequately
invested in combating domestic threats
i'd like to talk a little bit about our
non-profit security grant program
fema provides us to synagogues jewish
community centers
other non-profits houses of worship all
across this country to protect against
terrorist attacks
and in recent years dhs offices that we
have tried to prevent domestic terrorism
but do face
major cuts in personnel and funding the
department lacks a coherent strategy to
combat anti-semitism
and white supremacist extremism online
which far
too often unfortunately manifest itself
in real life actions
i'm co-chair of the senate bipartisan
task force combating anti-semitism along
with senator
lankford but i'd like to ask you
what are your plans for addressing
anti-semitism
as and really tackling these
online platforms that are promoting
anti-semitism
senator um
i am um profoundly
aware of the
threat and existence of anti-semitism
in our country and the world
my mother lost her paternal grandparents
and seven uncles by reason of their
jewish faith
in the holocaust my mother
fled her home with her parents
because of the holocaust i have
dedicated a considerable amount
of my personal and professional energy
to battling
in anti-semitism and discrimination
of all forms most recently i served on
the advisory board
of the secure community network
sponsored by the jewish federation to
protect
day schools synagogues and places of
worship
i have worked with the anti-defamation
league to battle
uh discrimination and hate of all
forms under my leadership as the deputy
secretary
of homeland security we grew the
non-profit grant program
to best protect minority communities
communities of faith from the scourge of
hate
and i would be privileged to work with
you in this committee
to make sure that we build on those
advances
and once and for all tackle this
challenge that has caused so much pain
to so many
thank you i have more questions if
there's a second round i'll yield back
my time
thank you thank you senators senator
hawley
thank you mr chairman uh mr mayorkas uh
thank you for being here congratulations
on your nomination
uh let me uh come back to a question
that senator scott asked a moment ago
regarding the border wall system and i
just wanted to follow up on your answer
to make sure
that i was clear as as you know congress
has recently appropriated and enacted
into law
1.4 billion dollars in additional
funding
for the border wall system my question
is i just wanted to be clear on this
or do you intend if you are confirmed to
obligate
and distribute those funds uh as they
have been allotted and designated by
congress uh senator hawley i know that
as i previously expressed
president-elect biden has committed
to cease funding for further
construction
of the border wall uh i would execute
uh president-elect biden's uh commitment
uh
um in adherence uh to the laws that uh
uh guide us
does that mean uh mr marcus that you
intend not to obligate
and uh and spend the funds as directed
by congress i mean i'm aware of the
president-elect's
commitment and i think it stands in some
tension with the law
past adopted uh and duly enacted by this
body so i just want to be clear on
on on where we're headed are you telling
me that that you don't think
that the 1.4 billion that has been
enacted that has been directed towards
the border wall system that you will not
you will not follow the law and obligate
that i'm just trying to understand
what your position is going to be well
uh senator let me let me um
if i may um strike at the fundamental
point
that i believe uh you were inquiring of
which is will i follow the law
and the execution of my responsibilities
should i have the privilege of serving
as the secretary of homeland security
and the answer is yes i will follow the
law and what i would need to do
is to understand what the law provides
with respect to
the obligation of funds to construct the
border wall
and and see what the opportunities are
to discontinue any such obligation
if in fact the law permits and act
accordingly
very good that that does answer my
question and you got right to the nub of
it which was
uh what you'll do with regard to the law
as it currently stands so uh
i look forward to seeing the actions
that you take there um
let me come back to to the subject of
immigration policy a little bit more
broadly
and speaking of the president-elect's
plans uh
he has said uh that he intends to
propose as early as his first day in
office so tomorrow
a plan for amnesty to up to 11 million
illegal immigrants now i have to tell
you i have concerns about that
especially in this time of severe
economic distress
that has fallen disproportionately on
working-class
americans give me a sense of
do you support a mass amnesty 11 million
is a very very large number
do you support mass amnesty on that
scale give me a sense of your thinking
on this
thank you for the opportunity to speak
that to that important issue senator
hawley
president elect biden has committed to
presenting congress on day one
uh with uh an immigration reform bill
that once and for all fixes i think what
we all can agree
is a broken immigration system and he
has spoken
um of the need for a
path uh to uh uh citizenship
for the individuals who have been in
this country for many years
who have contributed uh to our
communities and to this nation's
economic uh prosperity uh i would be
privileged
uh to work with congress uh to pass
immigration reform legislation that
provides
that path and provides a permanent
solution
to what is clearly a broken system
are you worried at all mr americas that
uh
amnesty on that scale such as envisioned
by the president-elect
will become itself a pull factor senator
scott mentioned
the recent migrant caravan from honduras
uh headed towards the united states that
appears to have been
disrupted in guatemala but do you are
you concerned
i'm concerned about the pull factor here
as well as the policy again
implications particularly as it relates
to working americans but
are you concerned about a poll factor in
an amnesty of that scale
senator hawley i i remember um the
bipartisan
uh piece of legislation uh that the
united states senate
um uh proposed a number of years ago uh
with the path to citizenship for
individuals who had contributed to our
nation's well-being
for many years and the fact that it
spoke uh
of certain requirements uh to ensure
that individuals who had been here
and contributed to the united states um
uh could
um gain uh that path
and those who had not yet arrived would
not
but with respect to the pull and push
factor
separately if i may uh senator hawley
let me speak to the push factor because
i don't think
its severity can be overstated
and i say this because president
election
um i think we need to address uh the
push factor
as the gravest challenge to a regular
migration
and therefore the investment in
countries
uh where so many people are fleeing
the investments in building a refugee
program
in the western hemisphere in the region
so that humanitarian relief is provided
and our border is not the first place at
which those needs are confronted
i think is a vital and underlying
solution
to the problem we confront
let me thank you for that let me uh ask
you two
more questions mr chairman i'll try to
be brief i want to ask you about the
migrant protection protocols
and i don't want to ask you about human
trafficking but just quickly mr mike was
on the micro protection protocols uh
this is as you know the trump
administration's policy of processing
migrants in mexico helping to restore
safe and orderly immigration process
while deterring those dangerous
crossings that you were just talking
about
do you do you anticipate uh continuing
to implement the migration
uh protection protocol calls or will you
will you uh end them
uh uh senator hawley um i think
you were cut off midstream in your final
question but i think i understand
uh your question which is uh would i
continue
um with the migration protection
protocols or mpp
is the ass as the acronym is known
president-elect biden
um has spoken of his commitment to end
the migration protection
protocols and i would execute on that
commitment should i have the privilege
of serving
uh as the secretary okay
last question mr chairman uh human
trafficking mr mayorkas
uh last october the department launched
a new
integrated operations system a center
rather for countering human trafficking
led by ice
they've had considerable success but
there is a tremendous amount of work
left to do as secretary of confirmed
would you continue to prioritize
combating human trafficking
and supporting ice in its and the
department as a whole in its battle
against this modern day form of slavery
i would senator i would look forward to
working with you in that regard
and i can share with you that for 12
years as a federal prosecutor
i focus considerable energy and effort
on combating human trafficking and
prosecuting
other perpetrators of it
thank you mr mayor thank you mr chairman
thank you senator hawley
uh we'll now go to a second round and i
know some
members were not able to stay let's make
this a lightning rod round
we're a lightning round we're going to
go quickly and try to get yes or no
answers
first we talked about the inspector
general report earlier i wanted to give
you a chance to respond to the second
part of it which was the
report that indicated that there were
employees whistleblowers
as they were called by the ig who
stepped forward and said that they were
poorly treated
at uscis how do you explain that over
15 of these employees from different
locations and employment levels provided
testimony on how they were treated
poorly by you how do you respond to that
mr chairman uh i'm very grateful to you
that you've asked that question because
um
i know you referenced uh that in your
opening statement and
quite candidly if you hadn't asked this
question of me
i would have requested the opportunity
to address it
before we adjourned this hearing
mr chairman my father
taught me a very important principle
and that is that an organization chart
is vertical when it comes to the
division of responsibilities
but it is horizontal and perfectly flat
when it comes to the stature of each and
every individual
in the organization and my father taught
me that
not by words but by how he conducted
himself
and i am immensely proud of the fact
that i have had adhered
to that lesson throughout my career as a
professional
and throughout my life as a human being
and senator mr chairman you can ask the
thousands of people
who have worked with me over my career
but how
i have conducted myself and i'm very
proud of that
fact and the fact is that's my greatest
source of pride the dignity and respect
with which i have treated others
and as a director of us citizenship and
immigration services
mr chairman as i mentioned before
i fix problems and sometimes fixing
problems
means making improvements and sometimes
making improvements means making change
and some people
aren't happy with change but change
improvement fixing problems is my
commitment
and i take stock in the fact that uh
just today an article was published uh
about me and um
i read in there uh mr homan's comment
mr holman was the leader of immigration
and customs enforcement during this
uh administration uh and he was the head
of enforcement and removal operations
when i served as a deputy secretary
mr holman and i disagreed on policy from
time to time but we had mutual respect
and what he said about me was the fact
that i always listened
that i always invited differing views
and i respected the articulation of them
i made my decisions
uh but i was fair and understanding and
open
and transparent in receiving and in
inviting
different views because that is an
obligation to make sure that we bring
the best thinking to the table on behalf
of the american people
i'm deeply proud immensely proud
of my conduct as a person and as a
professional
thank you that question wasn't
necessarily appropriate for a lightning
round i guess
um well i think we appreciate the answer
the question was perhaps my answer
wasn't
um i have to make a comment here with
regard to the ig because one of my
colleagues earlier
questioned the integrity of the ig and
as you know
uh mr john roth was the ig who issued
the report and substantially completed
it
his predecessor was the ig that my
colleague
was talking about and i just want to put
that on the record again not to have
anybody's reputation
on unfairly uh dismerged
in this process and mr roth by the way
was
widely regarded now a private citizen i
did speak to him about the report which
he stands by
and unanimously confirmed by by the
senate
so um let me ask you about
the particular issues on cyber security
you know i
can't do this in some detail in our
conversation
as you know the solar winds massive
breach
concerns all of us and frankly is not
that surprising given what we had been
finding which is that the federal
government is not well prepared
to deal with these kinds of breaches
that are going to be increasingly
a challenge for us cisa which is the
group within
the homeland security department you
talked about earlier uh i believe has
been stretched
too thin they did a great job on the
elections keeping cyber attacks from
happening
uh in the election but they
unfortunately during that same time
period did not
even know about the russian apparently
uh russian
uh massive cyber breach
can you comment on what cisa should do
going forward it's a new agency congress
have given them a lot of responsibility
i don't think we've given them an
adequate
mission that's focused enough or
adequate resources to be able to carry
out that mission
so that's that's my view but what is
your view on cisco what do you commit to
do
if you are confirmed with respect to
getting cisa on its feet as a
federal coordinating body to deal with
cyber threats uh
mr chairman um uh this committee
deserves uh tremendous praise
uh for standing up sisa uh as uh the
critical agency
in the department of homeland security
uh that really owns
uh the cyber security mission on behalf
of the department
uh and i think um uh congress deserves
credit
uh for the ndaa's provisions
are further equipping assisted to meet
its statutory obligations and the
challenges and opportunities
that it confronts sysa must
improve the cyber hygiene of the federal
government
the many departments and agencies
throughout it it must strengthen
the public-private partnership not only
for the benefit of course of the federal
government
uh but for the benefit of pri the
private sector uh
itself uh i take stock of the fact that
the solarium commission's recommendation
for a national cyber security director
uh was passed i think this is going to
require an all of government approach
and there's a great amount that will
rest on the shoulders of sisa
and i hope i have the privilege to lead
the department
and support sysa in meeting those
obligations
that's good you talked about cyber
hygiene the federal information security
modernization act also known as fisma
looks at the agencies every year and
decides how they're doing and
dhs cyber security program was rated
ineffective
so it's not just that system needs to
work on the rest of government
it needs to be a little work in-house uh
to be able to straighten that out
are you committed to doing that
absolutely um mr chairman we need to
lead by example
um we talked earlier uh a little about
the drug issue and as you know on the
author of the stop act which has
been effective at keeping some of this
fentanyl from coming in from china by
mail
unfortunately the department
particularly cbp has not been moving
forward as they should to be able to
implement that the cbp
regulations regarding how the stopback
will be implemented were due in october
of 2019
october of 2019 they still haven't been
finalized as a result
the stop act which said that we have to
require china to provide this advanced
electronic data on all packages by the
end of
last year so a couple weeks ago was not
met
and uh congress stepped in with my
support and we gave him another three
months otherwise hundreds of thousands
of packages would have been turned away
but we've got to get these regulations
um in place and we've got to be sure and
meet that new
march 15 deadline are you committed to
doing that to make sure those
regulations are put in place and that we
can get the stock back fully implemented
i certainly am um mr chairman and when
we last uh spoke you notified me of this
issue
um uh and i uh followed up and should i
have the privilege of being confirmed
uh one of my priorities will be to make
sure that we promulgate those
regulations because i very well
understand
uh the urgency of the threat that you
have identified
we've got to keep this poison coming in
our communities directly by our u.s mail
system
uh we know we have more to do on the
border now too because that's where
must've
shifted and you verify i take your
answer earlier to senator romney i
thought his question was excellent about
the need for us to strengthen you verify
it's not just a matter of
making sure that more companies step up
and voluntarily use it in my view it's a
matter of changing the program so it
it is more effective and specifically
obviously the issue of i
identification if you have false
identification fraudulently
uh obtained identification then the
program is not going to work effectively
will you commit to work with us on
dealing with the pull factor
which is the magnet of u.s jobs uh
senator i
i look forward to working with and
commit to working with this committee on
all issues that
come before the department of homeland
security but specifically i need to
verify are you willing to work with us
on strengthening that program yes i am
the trafficking center was talked about
earlier uh we do a lot of work
in this committee on the trafficking
issue homeland security also has
responsibilities i said earlier
it's it's one of my priorities can you
commit
to looking at this issue of elevating
the new center out of
hsi where it is now to the headquarters
level senator i would be pleased uh
to look at that and the capacity of the
headquarters uh to really administer
that most effectively i would like to
study that
issue and i commit to sharing my
findings with you
uh i understand the prioritization of
that mission set and whether
it belongs in headquarters or hsi is
something i would um
like the opportunity to review should i
be privileged to do so
given the mission i think it's much more
appropriate to be at the headquarters
level to be able to be effective and we
can talk about that
uh secret service uh i have talked to
you about this already my understanding
is that you think the secret service
should stay at the permanent homeland
security is that correct
yes it is um my concern
having known a lot of members of secret
service having been a protectee
is that they continue to be overworked
and undervalued
and they have enormous strain on them
including right now with regard to this
uh
inauguration tomorrow
would you agree to prioritize uh from a
staffing and budgeting perspective
ensuring that the secret service has
what they need to be able to do its
mission
i would mr chairman we look forward to
working with you on that
um there are a number of issues that
connected to today with regard to
anti-semitism and
pushing back against white supremacy one
of the things that we have done in this
committee
since you were last in government is we
have substantially expanded
the nonprofit security grant program to
help with regard
to all kinds of faith-based
organizations and non-profits
including synagogues and jewish
community centers so on that have been
under threat in my home state of ohio
specifically senator peters and i led an
authorization bill for the program that
we
got signed into law just last year
we also increased the funding this year
to 180 million bucks
and senator gillibrand and i are working
on some other
uh improvements to the program my
question for you is
are you willing to work with us and work
with
our partners around the country uh and
this is being done as you know through
fema
to ensure that we have adequate help for
these faith-based communities to
be able to push back against the
extremist threat number one and number
two
my longer-term concern is sustainability
many of these organizations are getting
grants
in ohio frankly a number of applied and
been successful
but to sustain these programs over time
whether it's cameras we've expanded the
program in the last couple years to
include
security personnel as an example or
whether it's simply
having the ability to to fully guard
against these attacks by having
um the facilities um hardened
against potential attacks the the
long-term sustainability of these
programs concerns me
and i wonder if you'd be willing to work
with us on that as well
i would on both counts um mr chairman
i'm very well aware of the
non-profit security grant program under
my leadership
and secretary johnson's leadership we
increased it
i'm very grateful to this committee for
increasing it further and i
will understand its needs thank you ms
marcus senator peters
thank you mr chairman uh mr may orcas uh
thank you for your testimony here you're
answering questions i should say lots of
questions we've
had you here for quite a quite a period
of time you've had a full range of
questions
to answer they've been very thorough
very thoughtful
and i'm just going to keep you here for
a couple more
that i'd like to have asked before we uh
close out this hearing
you've talked about technology and
infrastructure
investments there are a number of
questions by my colleagues that were
asked
along those lines and how we can secure
our ports of entry
there's no question the department of
homeland security has one of the most
difficult jobs you can
imagine that i as i think about when it
comes to border security
one you have to keep us safe every day
we expect you to do that at the same
time the economic activity that goes
across the borders
has to continue it has to happen in a
very efficient
manner i represent a border state in the
state of uh michigan i
oftentimes have to remind some of my
colleagues that there is a northern
border
in this country as well of the uh not
just the southern border
in fact if you look at the ports of
entry in michigan uh from
terms of uh the the land trade that goes
across it
uh we have we're two of the five busiest
border crossings in north america are in
michigan between canada if
if michigan were a country we'd be the
second largest trading partner
with with canada and so we have
demands there and needs and so my
question to you is that
we have to allocate resources you have a
northern border that demands resources
southern border you have our coastal
cities as well and ports of entry there
how do you see managing that and making
sure there are equitable
deployment of resources to deal with the
security threats
all across our country but also the
needs to be able to move trade
efficiently
across those borders in a secure fashion
ranking member
peters thank you very much i i traveled
the northern border
during my tenure as the deputy secretary
i well understand uh while much
attention is given to our southern
border we cannot neglect
uh the other borders uh northern border
and quite frankly
uh the um uh air and maritime uh
challenges that we as a country face
the the challenges that the department
of homeland security
confronts are many and varied
and um uh the department needs
a leader who understands them who works
incredibly hard
to meet all the many and varied
challenges
that knows how to prioritize mission
sets
and yet knows how to dedicate attention
and resources
to all of the responsibilities that we
as a department of homeland security are
obligated to fulfill on the american
on behalf of the american people i
respectfully and humbly submit
uh that i am qualified to do so and that
i would work with you
and other members of this committee to
make sure that all our borders
are protected uh against the challenges
that seek to do us harm
and that also the opportunities that the
borders present
in terms of the facilitation and
promotion of lawful trade and travel
are fully exploited for the benefit of
the american people
i commit to you that cooperation well i
appreciate that
uh and certainly the threats that we
face across all those borders
happen daily which is why this
appointment to this position is
absolutely critical to do it as quickly
as possible
we need to have steady leadership at the
department of homeland security
it's it's involved in what if you think
of all of the
demands that we have of government what
citizens expect from the federal
government i think it's safe to say
the number one priority for everybody
and the one that i believe passionately
is to keep us safe federal government
needs to keep us safe
that's the department of homeland
security is department of
defense and other uh folks who are
engaged
in in security but this position is
critical and hopefully we can fill this
as quickly as possible given of the
threats that we constantly face and i'm
just going to
close with one threat that i want your
sense of
your experience and your thoughts and
that is uh
biodefense we talk about a lot of other
security offenses but certainly
the pandemic has shown us the threat
that we get from
a biological threat that we have to
address that we have to mitigate
and federal preparations for disease
outbreaks also include things like
bioterrorism that could be used
by not a natural occurrence of
a bio threat like this pandemic but we
could be the subject of a bio-terrorist
attack
and there are other biological
challenges that all fit within the
department's responsibilities
but as you know biodefense uh like so
many of your responsibilities uh within
the
dhs it cuts across many different
federal agencies
so my question to you mr mayor is can
you speak about
what experiences you've had as a deputy
secretary that would inform you
as to how we should approach these
cross-cutting issues
uh like uh bio defense
uh uh thank you frank remember peters uh
let me
answer in uh in two parts number one
with respect to the department of
homeland security
internally within the department i had
the privilege
of getting to know the men and women in
the department
who focused on the particular threat of
which you speak
and i understand their qualifications
and capabilities
and it was um they were extraordinary
number one
number two i think you correctly point
out that this requires an
all-of-government
uh effort and it speaks to one of the
points i made in my opening
a remarks which is that fundamentally
the department of homeland security
is a department of partnership and we
must work with our federal partners
and our state and local tribal and
territorial partners to meet
the threats that we confront and that
includes the bio threat
of which you speak thank you mr mayor
chris
thank you for your willingness to serve
our country once again mr chairman thank
you
thank you senator peters uh mr mayorkas
uh thank you again for your testimony
this morning and we appreciate your
willingness to serve
especially at a time when our government
works to counter so many serious
threats and future threats as we've
talked about today
i also acknowledge that public service
is a family decision
and that involves family sacrifices so
we appreciate your daughters
and your wife being here today and
their support your decision to return to
public service
before we end today a few housekeeping
matters the nominee has filed responses
to biographical and financial
questionnaires answered pre-hearing
questions submitted by the committee and
had his financial statements reviewed by
the office of government ethics
without objection this information will
now be made part of the hearing record
and with the exception of the financial
data which are on file and available for
public inspection
in the committee offices all will be
available in the record
the hearing record will remain open
until 5 pm today
january 19 for submission of statements
and questions for the record
with that the hearing is adjourned
you